every day we sort of a react to what's
happening in Greece Lisa raised an
interesting question earlier this
morning do you think markets are
overreacting or under-reacting it
depends I guess on whether or not you
think that a potential greg's it is
actually a lehman style moment or not
right well I think the markets have sort
of trained themselves to assume that
some kind of last-minute deal is going
to be made we had a pretty funny story
out looking at the bookmakers in London
and if you want to bet that Greece will
stay in the euro you have to bet five
pounds to win one pound by the end of
this year so that gives you an idea you
know in other words the odds are totally
in favor of priests staying according to
bookmakers so whatever that's worth but
also today it you know as far as the
stock market goes you wake up and you
look at about a hundred billion dollars
worth of takeover deals granted rejected
which is not necessarily a bad thing if
someone comes back with higher deals but
Williams company and in all sorts of
deal talk in the insurance a healthy
yeah and some Cigna ok so maybe US
equity investors actually reacting to
M&A here and good economic data but Lisa
I thought our surgeon what you're saying
earlier you know ever I get all this
investor fatigue you know guests come on
the show and say oh it doesn't really
matter what happens to Greece it's less
than 2% of eurozone economy why should I
care but you say maybe actually markets
are under-reacting I thought this story
was really fascinating it was about
chief executive officers of pujo and
Siemens and other major European country
companies saying we're really concerned
about Greece if Greece leaves the
eurozone that could be a potential real
problem for the economy that's already
fragile I mean just even just the the
concept of a eurozone right you looked
at spanish yields over german yields
last week rising to the highest in more
than a year because people were
concerned about contagion people do
assume like to your point yes that
probably they will come to a last-minute
deal but there's a lot of question marks
about really what potential contagion is
it may not be like a lehman style event
I mean post people say it's not going to
be a Lehman style event it could be a
different style event though and i will
say that in septilin September 12 2008
there was an article about how money
market funds were saying that if the
Lehman if Lehman Brothers declares
bankruptcy everything will be fine
just saying market they don't always get
it right and sometimes you know people
it's hard to extrapolate out what
exactly would happen but yes today is
back on with risk on the moves aren't
dramatic in most of the markets and yet
it is risk on because people have been
expecting them to come to a deal and
frankly maybe the Euro finance ministers
are saying you know what we're not going
to risk it and so we are going to cater
to people who are maybe not dealing with
us the way we would want them to deal
with us by flogging or whatever else we
are moving things on Twitter but you
know this is a big question mark in
markets and people are scratching their
heads and saying what are we missing
could this be Lee yeah and Mike you've
got to wonder maybe is the US Treasury
market actually really thinking about
this yes obviously every way you look at
it the odds are or investors are placing
their bedside grease in fact we'll stay
in the euro but if they do actually
leave maybe that changes Jen the timing
of Jenny Ellen's rate hike it's possible
i think the you know this thing is
dragged on so long that it obviously
people expect a deal to be made but if
they were to leave would anyone be that
surprised so people have a lot had a
little i were they yeah i think i would
be the room has been waiting for I don't
know how surprised i'd be I mean and it
fell man investor I think I'd have you
know I'd have protected myself in the
event of an exit yellow is that the
strategist at JP Morgan had an
interesting no calling it basically a
sideshow and saying look most of the
obligations Greece has in the debt
market is to the ECB and you know the
IMF yet not a lot outstanding debt to
private investors right that has been
clearly something that the European
creditors have cleaned up in the past
couple years for example the exposure of
i'm thinking of french dutch italian
banks to greek debt has been
dramatically reduced right so as the
longer this has gone on the more
quarantined we sort of made the problem
so will there be contagion probably and
yeah you can't tell where it's going to
be but it seems like the contagion will
be a lot less than it would have been
say two or three years ago or five years
ago the alcohol Baker Remy had they're
concerned about Greek brandy so you know
you never know you know they've got a
certain kind of Greek brandy I'm
forgetting the name of it but wha no
that's fine
yeah but anyway so that you know there
are sort of visit collateral like what
is it that's gonna cause the market
today well tank but I mean there are
they sort of look little product like
three or four percent of their sales
something like that all right grease
aside what are the big mark and moving
events have besides deal activity that
you're looking out for this week
obviously I mean the deal activity today
is is the big story it's kind of you
know and this is when the market really
starts focusing on things like that
greased is when there's not a lot else
going on obviously earnings we solve a
couple weeks to go before the earnings
season starts and that's when really
everyone will focus back on the you know
the bottom-up fundamental information
coming into the market right now it's
sort of you know go from headline the
headline and really looking for
something you know the big question on
the stock market is where i'm in a
strong day today we're still not
breaking out of that range we've been in
all year no and you have two peas up
three percent year today right very sad
ways market yeah we had a straight-out
saying how polish the strategists are
and so they're holding tight to their
forecasts for person pretty good gains
this year but we just haven't seen it
yet so the markets kind of looking for
that next cattle is to break it out of
that trading range i'm watching the
inflation data this week i think that's
key and i think that any economic data
that we get that's out of the expected
ranges particularly to the upside if we
get you know more inflation than
expected that will cause some turmoil in
the bond markets